I was 16 when my brother died in a car
accident he was 19 and he'd been out
with all his friends drinking and having
fun they decided that my brother would
be fine to drive that he wasn't too
drunk um and he was supposed to turn a
corner and he just drove straight into a
tree nothing stays the same after
something like that and oh one decision
made by someone else has had so much
effect on so many other people's lives
he was so full of life and he has so
much potential and so being 20 now I'm
older than he ever was he'll ever be and
knowing knowing I have now and knowing
that he um will never have that because
I just I just think that people make
such abrupt decisions because they think
it would never happen to them they could
never happen to them but we all thought
at one all of my family all of tom's
friends even you never think it's going
to happen to you um but it did and we
have to live with that the aim of Yan is
truth is very simple to reduce the
number of young drivers killed and
seriously injured in road traffic
collisions on our roads we're working
with the police the fire service local
authorities and driving instructors to
try and make this happen about two to
three thousand people die on the roads
every year with thousands more being
injured serious road traffic collisions
are amongst the worst incidents that our
fire officer can attend unfortunately
our young drivers make up a large
proportion of those that are killed and
seriously injured as a result of those
collisions there are many different
reasons why young drivers are involved
in experienced distraction mobile phones
speed nothing quite prepare you for the
horrors you see the scene of the
collision but we've got a job to be done
one of the worst things and the most
heart-wrenching things about it is
happen to go and tell a parent that
their son or daughter has been killed
you will always be remembered that the
police officer who broke the worst news
ever going to hear our driving
instructors have a unique opportunity to
influence driving behavior at the very
start of a young person's driving career
the honest truth is a true partnership
giving driving instructors a seat at the
top table and making sure what we
provide them is worthwhile for too long
there has been a void between the public
services and driving schools and the
honest truth aims to bridge that gap the
project is growing from strength to
strength because of the enthusiasm of
the individuals involved in the agencies
and especially the drive and instructors
who have been on board with us from the
beginning of the project more driving
instructors should be involved in fact
all of us should be involved on the
driving community the authorities are
all working together for the first time
which is good to see but we should all
be involved not should be need to
believe there are many many different
initiatives across the country to try
and reduce these issues the honest truth
is designed to actually work with these
initiatives rather than standing on its
own our aim is not to patronize
instructors but to provide them with
free resources support and motivation to
help them deliver the safer driving
messages it's not only our job to teach
people to drive but to teach them to
live one small change can make a huge
difference and all we ask is that one
change is made by everybody on the roads
for the sake of people's families for
the sake of everyone they care about
well
the moment of madness really does lead
to what we all suffer which is
definitely a lifetime full of sadness
for the loss of my brother
you